lui répondit seconds ont fait la scène
finale bon il vous attend depuis deux
heures vous courez vers l'autre et vous
vous retrouvez enfin la fin du film on
vous a jamais vu comme ça ça nous évite
nous de payer une comédienne l'agencé la
scène finale qui la collecte et à
picoler encore attention quand je
direction vous courez au ralenti action
c'est bon le mouvement de la scène du
baiser final sur la bouche on leur fait
une dernière fois les i action action
et là vous sortez la langue un peu verra
pas les bactéries à la passion sortez la
langue encore là l'ont regardé la caméra
change un peu la donne un petit peu vous
trichez vous trichez genre vous trichez
mademoiselle boussole voilà mettez-vous
menton contre le menton ne vous
rapprochez pas aller si oui si j'en vois
la tob passé comme ça
je
oh
mais
la figure il c'est une petite scène
kaeppelin grande importance pour la
compréhension du film c'est très
important il attend son fils depuis deux
heures et vous vous arrivez evo10
instant l'acte arrive c'est au hockey
moteur action
alors ces affaires là que tu arrives il
va pas c'est pas de ma faute non pas
trop picolé et celle là c'est ta faute
le texte action alors c'est assez relax
arrive c'est pas de ma faute
céret ont fait la claque tout seul
jusque là jack pas de texte au corps ne
riez pas ne riez pas ne riez pas encore
la version 10 la scène ben je sais pas
ouais j'ai senti c'est bien mais c'est
jean carmet genre voulait faire on a
besoin d'un figurant pour la scène
finale du film
maintenant ça s'appelle j'en ai ras le
béret donc justement cherché quelqu'un
qui est un béret comme au hockey pee wee
un cachet à monsieur sera cachet
d'aspirine vous allez en prendre plein
la tronche
vous devez esquiver la nes qui vais pas
oui meritech la reflex sinon on va
vraiment vous bourrer la gueule action
mais voilà pas claquer la dernière année
la dernière vite parce que là faut qu'on
tourne la scène du viol avec monsieur
vite ça nous sommes de quoi les
corrections de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu